we have just about 45 minutes maybe 44
minutes because you may have to leave
punctually at one am I correct about
that so I want to I want to save most of
the time for your comments and questions
to which I will do my best to respond I
want to talk about three things briefly
I was asked to talk about leadership and
I will do so I want to talk about the
climate crisis and the solutions to the
climate crisis you'd be surprised if I
didn't and then I want to say a few
words on sustainable capitalism because
as B school students you are focused
naturally on the future of business and
I have strong views about the state of
business the state of markets and the
future of business first of all on
leadership I thank you for inviting me
to speak on the topic I don't hold
myself out as an expert on leadership I
think that based on my experience and
what I have tried to learn about
leadership I would start with the saying
by loud say who wrote of truly great
leaders that people will say we did this
ourselves worth reflection
I have studied leadership I've had the
privilege of being in a number of
positions where I was called upon to
provide leadership to organizations and
groups of men and women and there are
obviously many different styles of
leadership and all I can do is
speak to you about the style and
approach that I think makes the most
sense we as human beings are each
equipped with our own independent
ability to collect information process
it process the feelings and intuitions
that we have and make decisions
individually and as a part of groups
businesses are groups of people and
success is at the risk of a cliche a
team sport and the leader of a team has
to motivate individuals but has to be
conscious of the reality of the team how
do you do that let me give you a very
arcane analogy that's based on
information technology here we are in
Silicon Valley so maybe that'll be OK in
the history of computing the first
computers were based on central
processing units surrounded by fields of
memory and as the memory fields grew and
the processing power grew limitations to
that model soon appeared in structural
terms the central processing unit would
send out to the field of memory collect
data bring it back to the center process
it and then store the answer as the
speed requirements advanced it became
clear that this was a limitation both in
time and in the generation of energy
which had implications for the size and
materials necessary and design of
computers IBM's first breakthrough was
called vector processing its initial
success of
is really based on that advance which
simply meant that the central processing
unit when sending out to retrieve
process and then distribute the results
of information processing one of these
trips could begin while others were in
progress and so that saved time speeded
up the computer but all of the
processing still had to take place in
the central processing unit so in the
early 1980s a an architectural design
breakthrough took place empowered by the
relentless advance of Moore's law as
processors became smaller and more
powerful the central processing unit was
broken up and smaller micro processors
were placed throughout the field of
memory and with advances in software
design it became possible to issue the
Machine a start order at which moment
all of the information that needed to be
processed to produce the desired result
could be processed simultaneously
throughout the memory field where it was
stored adjacent to micro processors and
then the various fractions of the answer
could be brought to the center and
assembled so instead of three trips
there was one trip faster less heat
energy generated smaller machines faster
still a virtuous cycle so what does that
analogy have to say about leadership in
organizations if the leader of an
organization insists on being provided
all of the information necessary to make
every single decision
it is like the central processing unit
architecture and it is a cumbersome
process generating energy taking
and it does not maximize the assets of
the organization in the minds and hearts
of the men and women who make up the
organization so how do you make it
possible for a human organization to
process all of the parts of information
of the information available to the
organization simultaneously in real time
and then assemble the answer so that the
team as a whole can move swiftly and
effectively well to return to the
analogy in the analogy of the transition
and computing design from CPU base to
massively parallel processing
architectures the key is the software I
skipped right through that step very
quickly but obviously in order for the
start order to trigger simultaneous
processing by multiple processors
throughout the memory field and then
direct the parts of the answer toward
the center then assemble the answer that
requires very complex software so a
leader in a human organization has to do
something analogous to that software and
all simplifications can conceal as much
as they reveal so with that in mind I'll
just offer this simplification which is
hardly original with me but and you may
recognize it but vision values and goals
the vision of the organization is
central and the leader of any human
organization has to take primary
responsibility for communicating that
vision clearly I say communicating it
has to be shared not only in words not
only in data but emotionally spiritually
it has to be embodied in the way the
leader interacts with every part of the
organization
secondly values are central there has to
be an agreement as broadly and as
tightly as possible among all the
individuals in the organization on
values and what I mean by values is not
just what the the the word instantly
conveys but but but also I mean it in
this sense what ethical and business
criteria are supposed to be used in
making a decision if there is widespread
agreement among all of the individuals
in the organization about those criteria
about those values if you will then it
is more likely than not that any
individual in the organization
confronted with the same information
empowered by a commitment to pursue the
same vision will make a decision that is
quite similar to what anyone else in the
organization would make so there is a
congruence a vision of congruence of
values then goals there has to be a time
ordered sequence that reflects a
sensible priority listing of what goals
are most important at any given time and
there of course you know the old cliche
you have to avoid at all costs letting
the urgent displace the important
because a sense of urgency is simply not
the same as a sense of priority so the
role of a leader then begins to be
clarified at least in my mind the leader
of an organization has to take
responsibility for constantly elevating
the vision a rekindling a commitment to
the vision reiterating constantly
exactly what the vision is what is the
purpose of the organs
what are we trying to accomplish
together secondly the leader has to be
responsible for constantly reinforcing
the values of the organization not
Brooking compromise on core values and
also translating those values into the
practical criteria upon which decisions
are supposed to be based and the leader
third has to be responsible for keeping
track of the ever-changing list of
priority goals and the sequence in which
they are supposed to be pursued that to
me is a formula that works there are
other models there are there ways to go
about it but for my part that's what I
would like to share with you about
leadership now secondly the climate
crisis perhaps you know everything you
want to know about it but if you are not
personally thinking about and engaged in
the development of solutions for the
climate crisis then you haven't thought
clearly enough about it because by the
time you are my age it will be crystal
clear that the failures in the early
part of the 21st century to address
climate change effectively were
catastrophic ly tragic we still have
time to avoid the the worst unacceptable
consequences of the climate crisis but
we have to get busy right away and there
is a a massive amount of denial you know
the old cliche denial ain't just a river
in Egypt alongside that you could say
despairing just a tire in the trunk
there are people that move directly from
denial right through the oh my god
moment to despair without pausing to
actually saw
of the problem that needs to be
addressed and it seems a forbidding task
because the scale of the challenge is so
vast in essence we are facing a
completely new reality on this planet
and it is so new and so unfamiliar that
the temptation is to label it
implausible or at least to search out
for any acceptable excuse for doubting
whether it is real and holding on to
those doubts in order to justify waiting
before the the time when it's necessary
to really focus on it we don't have the
luxury of time anymore here the basic
facts global warming is simply the
largest and by far the most significant
manifestation of a deeper underlying
collision between human civilization as
it is presently organized and the
ecological system of the planet which
has empowered human beings and nourished
the flourishing of human civilization
there have been three changes that have
coincided to create a radical
discontinuity in the historical
relationship between the human species
and planet Earth
number one is population I won't belabor
this but when the scientists tell us
that we first emerged in roughly our
modern form approximately two hundred
thousand years ago
midway between the second to last and
third to last ice age we are a creature
for all seasons I'm going to resist the
temptation to go too deeply into any of
these points but be that as it may it
has taken two hundred thousand years be
for we reached a population of 1 billion
people sometime around the beginning of
the 19th century we added that many
people in the first 13 years of this
century we will add another billion in
the next 14 years and yet another
billion 15 to 16 years after that we we
may stabilize global population at 9 or
10 billion there is a good deal of
uncertainty about the projections simply
because the base is now so large that
fractions of a child an odd phrase I
know but fractions of a child in the
projections make the difference between
nine billion and fourteen billion or 18
billion we do know well let me pause and
say that this enormous population
explosion they used to call it it can be
looked at in retrospect by noting that
we have quadrupled human population in
less than a hundred years and that has
contributed to this radical change in
the relationship between our species and
the planet we could have many more
people with a completely different
lifestyle different technologies and a
different civilization but given the
stickiness of legacy technologies and
lifestyles it is fair to assume that we
really do need to stabilize population
in that regard we are witnessing a
success story unfolding in slow motion
actually we have seen the development in
the last quarter century of a very
powerful and durable consensus worldwide
on exactly how to stabilize population
this is a success it doesn't look like
it but but sometimes but it is it's a
systems problem population dynamics is
not a single call
single effect issue there are multiple
factors involved but here is the
distillation of what social scientists
have learned and proven in the field
there are four factors all of which have
to be present but when these four
factors are present in any society
population changes from one equilibrium
state to another equilibrium state it's
an s-curve the first equilibrium state
is high birth rates
high death rates and large families down
the s-curve at the end of the transition
the demographic transition as they call
it there is a second equilibrium state
small low birth rates low death rates
and small families small families are
actually preferred by people during the
Agricultural Revolution there was a
premium on having larger families there
are many other factors involved but
basically the challenge has been how to
move societies around the world from one
equilibrium state to the other that's
where these four factors come in number
one the education of girls number two
the empowerment of women number three
the ubiquitous or nearly ubiquitous
availability of fertility management
techniques and technologies and
knowledge number four perhaps most
significantly low child death rates how
does that last one fit in if parents
have confidence that their children will
survive into adulthood and they have the
ability to manage fertility they're
going to want smaller families if on the
other hand there is a high child
mortality rate then mothers and fathers
will want to have large families in
order to ensure
some of their children survive into
adulthood particularly in in societies
where there are not social security type
programs and family support is essential
in in old age now the good news is we
made a lot of progress in educating
girls and empowering women
not nearly enough but we are on the
right track all over the world we have
also made a lot of progress in reducing
child death rates really quite dramatic
progress where we have lagged behind is
making fertility management available
particularly in places like sub-saharan
Africa where the replacement rate is
still much higher than than the global
average Africa as a consequence midway
through this century not long from now
we'll have more people than either China
or India and at the end of this century
we'll have more people than China and
India combined but in much of the world
this transition the demographic
transition has taken place in all the
developed countries North America Europe
Japan etc even in in China Brazil the
BRICS the emerging economies there
they're all Mexico they they they are
all coming down this s-curve
so this is good news it's a a positive
development but those that have that are
not getting fertility management have a
right to expect that wealthy developed
countries principally the United States
will actually follow through on the
pledges made to help them get access to
fertility management this is the the one
problem there anyway that's the first
factor even though it's a success story
the large increase in population has
changed the relationship we have to the
planet second and far more significant
is the technology revolution that took a
turn one hunt
fifty years ago after the Industrial
Revolution powered by coal the first oil
well was drilled a century and a half
ago and in the 20th century the
combination of oil and coal became the
basis of energy in the world and today
eighty-five percent of the energy used
by Earth Inc the global economy comes
from fossil fuels and as a result we now
put 90 million tons every day of
heat-trapping global warming pollution
that's dumped into the atmosphere every
24 hours as if the atmosphere is an open
sewer you know in the nineteenth century
a great doctor in England was dealing
with a cholera epidemic which used to be
one of the biggest killers and he
innovated a location-based data system
and mapped all of the cases of cholera
in London and overlaid it on the sewer
system and found that a single
malfunctioning pump on Broad Street was
the proximate cause of the cholera
epidemic not long after that Louis
Pasteur discovered the bacteria that was
responsible for cholera and it is no
longer the the major cause of death in
the world that it used to be he
connected the dots and it traced to the
sewer system we have to connect the dots
between the 90 million tons of global
warming pollution spewed into the
atmosphere every day the decision to use
the atmosphere as a sewer and the and
the resulting consequences of all that
extra trapped heat we're raising the
temperature of the planet in fact the
accumulated man-made global warming
pollution now traps as much extra energy
in the in the atmosphere every day as
would be released by 400,000
hiroshima-style atomic bombs every
single day it's a big planet but that's
a lot of energy and that's what's
evaporating much more water vapor from
the oceans into the warmer air of the
fear which has an increased holding
power holding capacity for water vapor
so when storm conditions release a
downpour the storms reach out 2,000
kilometers often and funnel these rivers
of water vapor in the sky into these
massive downpours that are breaking
records all over the world creating
these floods the same extra heat is
pulling the moisture out of the soil
making massive droughts much more
widespread and much more frequent the
extra heat and the oceans is powering
much stronger wind speeds which makes
the storms more destructive melting the
ice 50% of the Arctic ice cap is now
gone as of last September all of it will
be gone in in the next 10 20 years and
that's changing the the pattern of the
jet stream and the storm tracks it is
disrupting the age the the timing of
precipitation events and the clockwork
of rainy season dry season alternation
in in developing countries disrupting
sustainable agriculture not sustainable
a subsistence agriculture in countries
where that is the principal occupation
the melting ice raises sea level you
know the rest
moves disease vectors from the tropics
and subtropics into the temperate zones
and the list of horribles is actually
much longer than that
the tendency in the face of such
evidence is to turn away from it and
that is that leads to the third cause
after population and technology and that
is our way of thinking we are empowered
with thought patterns and habits that we
have inherited from our ancient
ancestors and as has often been the case
in the history of civilization our real
challenge is to accelerate the emergence
of wisdom that can be used to deal with
new circumstances we're built for that
we are
creatures of habit we we we do manifest
the legacies of our evolutionary past
but we also have the capacity to rise
above our limitations and to see clearly
the changes that need to be made one of
the things that needs to change is our
vulnerability to short-term thinking now
our present to culture in business in
media in politics in almost every realm
of life has now magnified this tendency
to focus on the short-term and made it a
very serious problem so let me use that
as a segue to the third topic that I'll
cover very briefly and then open it up
to your questions and comments
sustainable capitalism short-term ISM
you no doubt have already identified
that as a buzzword it is an extremely
serious problem one of our leading
business research institutions BNA
conducted a famous study a few years ago
in which they asked CEOs and CFOs a
whole series of questions one of them
was a hypothetical here's a an
investment you can make in your business
the question began if you make this
investment your business will become
more profitable stronger more
sustainable more resilient it meets your
internal investment targets but there's
one issue if you make this investment
you will slightly miss your next
quarters earnings projection given those
facts will you make the investment 80%
said no that is functionally insane it
truly is because it hurts the
shareholders it hurts the employees it
hurts the communities where the business
is operating but it is now a routine
decision because of course missing a
quarterly earner
projection leads to a reduction in
market capitalization and whatever
benefits come from focusing on the
long-term build up of sustainable value
could can be wiped out given the way
financing markets now operate so what do
we need to do to reform capitalism let
me first say it hardly needs to be said
particularly in this group but
capitalism's capitalism is the best way
of organizing economic activity ever
created it allocates resources
efficiently balances supply and demand
is more congruent with higher levels of
freedom in human societies and perhaps
most significantly capitalism unlocks a
higher fraction of the human potential
with a ubiquitous set of organic
incentives that routinely reward hard
work initiative creativity and and
innovation but in spite of those well
documented strengths which have made
capitalism the base of every successful
economy in the world and there are
different varieties of capitalism but in
essence it is ubiquitous now but in
spite of those strengths capitalism is
increasingly being associated with a
series of problems growing inequality
almost everywhere in the world the US
Europe Japan China India Brazil almost
everywhere in the world inequality is
growing beyond the normal levels
inequality is endemic to capitalism it's
good we should have inequality that's
part of the design that's part of why
this system of incentives works but as
with inflation if you go from a normal
level to a hyper level hyperinflation
soaks up so much energy and so many
resources that the normal functioning
comes almost to a halt hyper inequality
is threatening to both keep both the
capitalism and democracy since the
every such as it is began after the
recent Great Recession 93 percent of the
additional income in the United States
has indeed gone to the top one percent
that's not an Occupy Wall Street slogan
that's a fact
oh and while these flows of income have
been channeled to the top middle income
families have been struggling and are
increasingly struggling okay this is not
a political polemic it is an observation
and the consequences of this again are
threatening to democratic capitalism
what else a series of disruptions in the
global economy occurring with greater
frequency and at higher magnitudes
misaligned incentives we're not just
principal-agent problems but misaligned
incentives that lead to allocation out
of decisions and investment decisions
that again don't make good rational
sense these problems need to be
addressed an increasing focus on the
short-term as I said earlier so what
should we do I think that there are need
to be some significant reforms in the
design of markets and in the design of
capitalism since this ubiquitous set of
organic incentives is the key to
unlocking the energy in markets we need
to pay careful attention to what the
incentives are people will often do what
you pay them to do and if you pay them
to focus on the short term they will do
that even if you also signal to them
that you want them to tell you that
they're focused on the long term if you
reward them and pay them to focus on the
short term they will do that 30 years
ago in the US the average holding period
for public equities was roughly 7 years
which is congruent with the build-up of
real value in firms now it's less than 6
months and on both the New York and
London exchanges more
and a half of the trades are now made in
by algorithmic computer trading in in
milliseconds so we need to get rid of
this idea that more liquidity is always
better we do not have perfect
information markets do not tend toward
equilibrium and we need to understand
that the standard model is now obsolete
what will the new model be I don't know
a lot of people think behavioral
economics and behavioral investing is
the leading candidate I kind of think
that but it's above my pay grade so I
will let you all figure that out let me
conclude and then open it up to you by
telling you just just one brief story
because the climate crisis can seem
daunting the challenge of fixing
capitalism can seem daunting but look
things can change very quickly I
remember as a child as a young guy and
growing up in Tennessee when the civil
rights revolution swept the country I
remember when the conversation changed
somebody made some racist comment and my
circle and somebody else said now we
don't go for that and it in in millions
of conversations had changed two months
ago saw an article about two gay men
waiting in a long line for pizza holding
hands some homophobe walked by made a
nasty comment literally every other
person in that line turned on the
homophobe it said hey shut up we don't
go for that anymore we're winning that
conversation when the culture shifts
when consciousness changes then
everything else can change rapidly you
may have noticed countries all around
the world are approving gay marriage
getting rid of the discrimination
against gays and let's somebody had
asked in your age group you wouldn't
have been surprised at all but in my age
group if somebody said five years ago we
would see this revolutionary change most
people would have said I can't do it
we're doing it because consciousness
changed that's what has to happen with
the conversation about
global warming unsustainable capitalism
now finally I remember as a boy of 13
when President Kennedy issued the
challenge to put a person on the moon
and bring him back safely in 10 years
and I remember hearing so many say
that's a mistake we can't do that but
eight years and two months later Neil
Armstrong set foot on the moon and the
moment he did so there was a great cheer
that went up in NASA's Mission Control
in Houston the average age of those
systems engineers was 26 which meant
when they heard that challenge they were
18 I know that some of you have come
here to this great institution to be of
a part of something larger than yourself
I would end by challenging all of you to
aim in that direction these are times
when it is a privilege to have the
opportunity to do good things at what
will be looked back upon as a turning
point for human civilization and
business is at the center of the change
that has to take place so we need the
will to act but always remember that the
will to act is itself a renewable
resource thank you very much I'll open
it up to your questions
thank you
thank you very much okay we don't have
much time
don't don't waste it on simply
applauding where am I going
okay yes mr. president thank you so much
tell me who you are when yes I'm sorry
names Alec stars even MBA one here
wanted to ask you more specifically
about the inequality you are mentioning
I've heard a lot are you here often
people mention that maybe that's just
the way the economy is moving that you
know the way as it goes to a more
advanced information economy that
there's the nature of where the jobs are
that inequality is a natural progression
a do you agree or disagree with that
assuming you disagree with that how do
you get it to the point where you close
that inequality gap well I I do disagree
with it I I think that there are
obviously some very broad structural
factors involved since it's a nearly a
global phenomena there are a few
countries in South America that don't
manifest it in the words of the song
they've been down so long it looks like
up to them but in the rest of the world
it's it's pretty ubiquitous I think
there are a lot of factors involved I
think the emergence of Earth Inc with
the combination of outsourcing and robo
sourcing advanced automation is a big
part of it so that business is operating
with global supply chains and the
ability to outsource with the
transportation revolution and the
internet now a routinely look at labor
as the first place to cut and in
contrast to the Industrial Revolution
when people standing on assembly lines
were making good money and buying the
products coming out of the factories now
the increasing levels of automation that
now extend not just our physical
capacities but also our cognitive
functions are really creating a very big
systemic change the so-called Luddite
fallacy that's been accepted for since
Ned Ludd led his revolt
may no longer be a fallacy that's
controversial to say but an increasing
number of really good economists are
coming to that conclusion and I think
that has an impact here in the United
States I think that tax policy has had a
major impact on inequality I think that
our democracy is in in trouble that's
another topic and not the one that I'm
talking to about here but I think that
elites now have outsized power I I think
there's been a big structural change in
the way we communicate the the
revolution of the printing press really
led to the Enlightenment and the
emergence of representative democracy
the shift in the last third of the 20th
century to a television based ecosystem
really changed that there's a bottleneck
through which you can gain access to the
public's mind only if you have huge
amounts of money so corporate special
interests now dominate the messaging
that comes into everybody's living room
and on their screens and the average
American in spite of the Internet's
arise still watches television 5 hours
per day now as the internet gains
momentum and scale television will sink
into the digital universe you're seeing
it begin to happen now and the
architecture of the internet-based eco
information ecosystem is similar to the
print ecosystem in this sense
individuals have very low entry barriers
and once again reason can be lifted up
as a substitute for wealth and power and
then changes in labor markets and tax
laws and political systems can once
again begin to reflect the public
interest but one way or another this
these levels of hyper inequality are
unsustainable and they're very dangerous
as I said both the democracy and
capitalism hi my name is Branca MBA -
I'm from Brazil I'm curious about your
point about increasing focus in the
short
and I hear a call to action to future
business leaders and I just wanted to
understand why do you how do you think
about the public sector in the private
sector at least here in the US and how
these two should like coordinate to make
sure that like we can change that
mentality yeah I I think that the the
the dividing line between private goods
and public goods is in need of clear
focus and attention now democratic
capitalism has ideological hegemony in
the world and has at least since the
Berlin Wall fell in 1989 but that
engendered a kind of triumphalism among
market fundamentalists and the the
internal dividing line between in
democratic capitalism between those who
are primarily rooted in the democracy
sphere and those who are primary are
half sphere and those who are primarily
rooted in the market hemisphere that
line began to shift and power is now
being pulled from political systems into
markets and both capitalism and
democracy by the way are manifestations
of this massively parallel processing of
information that I began by describing
in the context of leadership think about
it and both were invented the same year
1776
that's when Thomas Jefferson wrote the
Declaration of Independence that's when
Adam Smith published The Wealth of
Nations and in both systems you see the
the the the independent decisions of
multitudes of people collected to
harvest the wisdom of crowds in
democracy and the invisible hand in
markets both systems have been hacked
and I don't know if you've seen the the
work of he's long since of dead but
Mansur Olson is one of several theorists
who has described how elites over time
during long periods of stab
ten naturally to accumulate more power
and influence that's happened in the
political system it's happened in the
market system I do think that one of the
solutions to inequality and growing
structural joblessness is going to be to
put new emphasis on the generation of
public goods now let me say one other
thing briefly the dashboard the compass
the the the the metric system that we're
using to guide economies is completely
whacked GDP and the national accounts
that are derived from GDP and business
accounting in 1937 the creator of a
gross domestic product Simon Kuznets was
honored for it and he said thank you
very much it I know it's an advance
really you know it really was but he
said please do not use this as a guide
for National Economic Policy why because
it's a heuristic you know a $10 word
that means shortcut but a little more
than that a shortcut that that becomes
embedded in our thinking and we think
it's the whole thing but it's a shortcut
GDP leaves out a lot what does it leave
out does not take into account pollution
flows environmental externalities does
not matter that measure the distribution
of income so inequality doesn't show up
on the dashboard if we get an increase
in national income and 93 percent of it
go it does go to the top one percent
that's a big win for all of us right
well no but on the dashboard it looks
like it's it's it's a big win what else
is left out
well depletion of natural resources but
here's the one that I'm getting to in
addition to negative externalities like
pollution positive externalities are
left out so that if a community or a
nation invests in education mental
health care community building etc that
shows up as an expense but the positive
benefits that come flowing back into
society are not measured they're not put
on the balance sheet and so when we face
a fiscal
challenge to you know rebalance the
books you want to cut that spending
without but if you have no knowledge
that you're also eliminating all of
those benefits you know I mean
infrastructure people understand that
that's a public good because it's
measured derivatively
from the stuff that is on the the
balance sheet that depends on the
infrastructure but education mental
health care these other things they're
not measured so we really do have to
take a close look at this now let me say
we're going to run out of time but I
want to challenge all of you to use the
skills and talents that you're acquiring
here and congratulations on being
accepted here on being able to stay here
on doing what you're doing but to whom
much is given much is required that's
another cliche but but I want to leave
you today I know that they're gonna be I
don't know if you ring a bell or blow a
whistle or or what but I don't want to
be caught standing while everybody gets
up and leaves so so let me just conclude
by thanking you for the opportunity to
spend this time with you I'm very very
grateful but I want to conclude by
challenging you we need your help this
is really and truly a moment not only
unlike any other it's it's different in
kind this is a moment when all of us
really have to rise to an unprecedented
challenge and years from now when you're
my age your kids you know we'll look
around them at the world that they live
in and they'll ask one of two questions
you know if there are hundreds of
millions of climate refugees and
failures of governance and countries
around the world at rising seas and
stronger storms and deeper droughts and
bigger floods and a collapse of of
civilized norms and different places
challenges to the food supply and the
waters they look at they would be
justified in asking you why do you do
anything about this but if they look
around them and see a world in renewal
with a massive
shift to renewable energy and deficiency
and whole systems thinking and a sense
of hope in people's hearts and a
regeneration of the life and vitality of
the earth and of human populations they
will ask you how did you rise to this
challenge and you have to decide which
of those questions you want to answer
while you're here and equip yourselves
to be a part of given and part of the
answer will be that you went to Stanford
Business School you got the skills and
knowledge and then you decided to use
them in an effective and appropriate way
thank you very much for having me here
today
you go thank you